he is a royal US authorities want to
speak to as they investigate a dead
billionaire sex offender she's the wife
of an American intelligence officer
wanted by British police after a fatal
road accident two different individuals
two different stories but people
representing alleged victims in both
were today pointing to what they have in
common
it's about evasion of justice now these
are the two greatest allies in the world
that follow a rules-based system no one
no matter who you are whether you're
Prince Andrew and secured or frankly
Donald Duck or Mickey Mouse is above the
law the parallels between the two cases
are eerie Harry Dunne was 19 Kiki was 19
billionaire Jeffrey Epstein killed
himself in jail awaiting trial for
multiple sex offenses one of his alleged
victims Virginia Roberts claimed she was
forced to have sex with Prince Andrew in
2001 after a night at tramps nightclub
the Prince denies being there but today
there were fresh details about claims by
one eyewitness that she saw him that
night at the club she looked at who he
was with and it was a very young girl
about her age and in the photographs
that she has seen since she identifies
that young woman as our girl I should
say as Virginia Roberts Prince Andrew
was a friend of the convicted sex
offender but denies any wrongdoing and
so far has not answered calls to come to
America and help investigators today one
of Epstein's other victims called on the
Queen to persuade her son to do so I
really feel pathetic for the Queen I
can't imagine what she's going through
is shameful but I think that they should
pressure him to do the right thing
both Harry John's family and lawyers for
Jeffrey Epstein's victims both cases are
very different and separate but they say
there are enough similarities to justify
joining forces and urging authorities on
both sides of the
to do more to deliver justice Dominic
Waghorn Sky News in New York